biden's body bags that's the focus of
tonight's angle
for the past week biden and his team
have spun over and over that the
evacuation was going well
well today we saw the truth this was all
total crap this is a catastrophe
and if you and your team mr president
can't handle this mission why should we
trust you to handle any mission
our enemies know that we're being led by
a band of incompetence and none of them
are shaking in their boots from this
biden promise
for those who carried out this attack
know this
we will not forgive
we will not forget
we will hunt you down
and make you pay
the fact is president biden and his
hand-picked military leaders have failed
the american people
they failed to bring and build an afghan
army to withstand the taliban they
failed to organize a withdrawal that
didn't devolve into total chaos
and they failed to first extract
americans still in harm's way and
instead
they prioritize afghan nationals
as far as we know hundreds of americans
still remain in afghanistan
how many more men and women in uniform
might die because blinken millie and the
rest have no idea what they're doing
these young men and women joined the
military to serve and protect their
country
but now they're forced to serve under
leaders who couldn't run a school
crosswalk
all americans should have been withdrawn
weeks ago not in the last moments
so once they created chaos all around
the airport it created an impossible
situation one that allowed isis
militants to murder our
soldiers just like joe biden created a
magnet for illegals and the cartels at
the southern border
his plan created a magnet for terrorists
at the airport in kabul
we expect those attacks to continue and
we're doing everything we can to be
prepared for those attacks that includes
reaching out to the taliban who are
actually providing the outer security
court and around the airfield to make
sure they know what we expect them to do
to protect us
is he even listening
to how insane he sounds
he's the head of centcom we're relying
on the people
who we've been at war with for the last
20 years for protection and safe passage
now we're letting them play tsa for us
in kabul
of course that's not even the worst part
it turns out that the biden
administration
actually gave their taliban counterparts
a list of americans in country
and a list of afghans okayed for
evacuation
there have been occasions when
our military has contacted their
military counterparts
in the taliban and said we want you to
let that bus or that group through i
can't tell you with any certitude
that there's actually been a list of
names i know there may have been but i
know of no circumstance it doesn't mean
it's not didn't exist we're just
counting on their self-interest
to continue
to generate their activities
and it's in their self-interest
that
we leave when we said
and that we get as many
people out as we can
it's actually scarier hearing that the
second time around by the way i only
heard it once that was the second time
it's terrifying i cannot believe this is
happening in the united states of
america
encouraging thousands of desperate
afghanis to flock to that airport of
course just an idiotic endeavor we we've
seen it play out at our southern border
desperate migrants they're rushing in
and it's just pain and suffering caused
along the way these are purely political
calculations that biden's team has made
they wanted millions of migrants at the
southern border they got them and now
they want hundreds of thousands of
afghan refugees here in the united
states and we're on track to get that
number as well
my friends
they cannot be allowed to continue this
this cannot be allowed to happen
joe biden has proved himself to be
completely incompetent
a single american serviceman or woman
should not die
under the regime that they've created
the military leaders from mili to the
head of central command to what we've
seen in our secretary of defense lloyd
austin
none of them
should be still in their positions none
of them
accountability is something we need in
washington d.c and i remember earlier
this week we heard biden and his team
saying oh now is not the time anthony
blanken now is not the time to ask these
questions no
now is the time
to ask these questions now is the time
to demand accountability hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else